>> AND AMERICAN POWER COUPLE
HITTING FOR SPLITS FILL.
TOM BRADY AND GISELE BUNDCHEN
HIRING DIVORCE LAWYERS IN A
MESSY MULTI-MILLION-DOLLAR
SEPARATION.
THE TWO ALLEGEDLY LIVING
TOGETHER FOR MONTHS FOLLOWING AN
EPIC FIGHT AND SO FAR
TIGHT-LIPPED AND WERE NOT
RESPONDING FOR COMMENTS.
RUMORS OF A ROCKY RELATIONSHIP
FOLLOWING SINCE TOM BRADY
RETURNED TO THE NFL.
BACK IN AUGUST BRADY TOOK 11 DAY
ABSENCE FROM TRAINING CAMP TO
DEAL WITH PERSONAL ISSUES.
DANA, TO YOU FIRST.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
QUESTION MARKS BEFORE AS A
MARRIED PERSON AND WE WERE
TALKING DURING THE BREAK, YOU
NEVER KNOW WHAT A MARRIAGE IS
LIKE BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE.
I FEEL FOR THEM THAT THIS IS
PLAYING OUT ON PAGE 6 AND HERE
ON "THE FIVE."
BUT IT IS AN AMAZING COUPLE THAT
WE HAVE WATCHED FOR YEARS.
THEY ARE BOTH UTIL FULL PEOPLE
AND THEY HAVE GREAT KIDS.
WE ALL THOUGHT, "EVERYTHING IN
THEIR LIFE IS PERFECT."
IT IS A GOOD REMINDER JUST WHEN
YOU THINK SOMEBODY ELSE IS
HAVING THE PERFECT
LIFE, EVERYONE IS GOING THROUGH
SOMETHING.
I WISH THEM THE BEST AND I HOPE
THEY CAN WORK IT OUT.
>> Jessica: AGREED.
SO JESSE, GISELE DID AN
INTERVIEW A LITTLE WHILE THE
COLD AND TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
SHE CONSISTENTLY COMPLAINED TO
BRADY HE WAS NOT AROUND ENOUGH.
AND THEN HE AND RETIRES AND SHE
THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE
A NORMAL LIFE SUPERSTAR LEVEL.
DO YOU THINK HE WILL REGRET THIS
POTENTIAL FINAL SEASON IN THE
NFL?
>> Jesse: IT DEPENDS ON HOW
THEY DO.
IF THEY WIN THE SUPER BOWL, NO.
IF THEY DON'T WIN THE
SUPER BOWL, YES.
I HAD A GREAT LINE, "TOM BRADY
IS MARRIED TO FOOTBALL."
THAT IS THE MAN'S MISSION.
THAT IS HIS MISSION FOR LIFE.
AND A MAN ON A MISSION, THEY
WILL PURSUE THAT.
AND I HEARD SOMETHING...
[LAUGHTER]
AND PURSUE THIS MISSION, AND
TRADITIONALLY, THE WIFE IS THERE
TO SUPPORT THAT MISSION.
SHE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR HIM
LEAVING NEW ENGLAND.
I HEARD THAT FROM A VERY TRUSTED
SOURCE.
SHE SAID, "TOM YOU DON'T NEED
BILLET CHECK YOU CAN DO THIS BY
YOURSELF.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING ENOUGH
CREDIT."
HE GOES DOWN TO TAMPA AND WINS
THE SUPER BOWL, IN THE PLAYOFFS,
AND COMES BACK AND RETIRES.
THIS WHOLE THING WAS HER IDEA TO
LEAVE BOSTON AND GO DOWN AND WIN
RINGS IN FLORIDA.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON, BUT I AM ON TOM'S SIDE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BACK UP YOUR LITTLE NOISE THAT
YOU MADE?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT DID YOU
SAY?
TOM IS MARRIED TO HIS SPORT?
>> Jesse: HE IS MARRIED TO
FOOTBALL.
>> Judge Jeanine: TO FOOTBALL,
OKAY.
HERE IS THE THING, GISELE,
NUMBER ONE IS A SUPERSTAR MODEL.
WHO, I BELIEVE IS WORTH MORE
THAN TOM IS.
>> Jesse: CASHES IN ON THAT
FOX BROADCASTING GIG.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: SHE WILL STILL BE
WORTH MORE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE SHE
SUFFERED FOR YEARS, PULLING BACK
ON HER OWN CAREER AND TAKING
CARE OF THE KIDS, MAKING SURE HE
COULD PURSUE THE CAREER HE LOVED
WHEN SHE HAD ONE THAT WAS JUST
AS FAR SUCCESSFUL AND JUST
FINANCIALLY -- AND FRUSTRATED BY
THIS BUT SHE ENDED UP SUPPORTING
HIM AND GOT UP AT 5:30 IN THE
MORNING.
THEY DIDN'T NEED THIS, THEY
DIDN'T NEED THAT AND EVERY HOUR
HE HAD TO DO SOMETHING AND SHE
WAS THERE WITH THE KIDS BUT SHE
PULLED BACK ON EVERYTHING SHE
DID TO SUPPORT HIM.
HE SAID, OKAY, IT IS YOUR TIME.
YOU ARE 45, TOM, GET OVER IT!
>> Jesse: THE OFF-SEASON HE
WASN'T WAKING UP...
>> Judge Jeanine: THEY HAVE
THE SAME SCHEDULE.
THE GUY IS OBSESSED WITH THIS.
IT IS TIME...
>> Greg: SHE WENT THROUGH WITH
A FABULOUS HUSBAND WHO PROVIDED
FOR THEM.
>> Judge Jeanine: NO, NO, NO,
NO, SHE HAD HER OWN CAREER.
>> Greg: SHE WAS A MOTHER.
CAN I SEE SOMETHING?
>> Judge Jeanine: I'M NOT
FINISHED.
I'M NOT FINISHED.
I'M ON HER SIDE.
>> Greg: I THINK LOTS OF WIVES
CAN SAY THEIR HUSBANDS ARE
MARRIED TO FOOTBALL.
LOOK, IS A FELLOW FELLOW, SARAH
PADRE, I WANT TOM TO KNOW THAT
I'M HERE FOR HIM IF HE WANTS TO
TALK.
BUT THE TOM/GISELE STORY DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE IF YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE OPTIONS.
IF YOU SAY, OPEN MY GOD WHY
WOULD HE LEAVE HER OR WHY WOULD
SHE LEAVE HIM?
IT IS SIMPLE, THEY HAVE OPTIONS
YOU DON'T, RIGHT?
THEY HAVE REACHED BEAUTIFUL
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE SUFFERING AND THEY
CAN'T STICK TO ONE THING BECAUSE
THERE IS ALWAYS SOMETHING
BETTER.
YOUNGER.
YOU KNOW, MOST PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
TOM AND GISELE OPTIONS.
AS A WORLD FAMOUS CELEBRITY, I
UNDERSTAND THIS.
OPTIONS TO MANY ARE THE
FORBIDDEN FRUIT.
A BOOK FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME, THEY
ARE THE FRUIT BEER THEY ARE
EVERYWHERE.
I CAN PUT THEM IN AT ANY TIME.
IT MAKES THE MOST PERFECT AND
BEAUTIFUL MARRIAGE EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE THAN THE HIGH SCHOOL
JANITOR MARRIED TO HIS
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART.
THAT COULD BE A STRONGER MARY
BECAUSE THAT IS ONLY OPTION
EITHER OF THEM HAD.
BUT THEY CAN HAVE -- LIKE IF SHE
WANTS, SHE CAN DATE ME BUT
OBVIOUSLY I'M IN A RELATIONSHIP.
BUT I COULD WEIGH THE OPTIONS,
RIGHT?
THEY COULD FLIP LIKE BRAD PITT
AND ANGELINA, THEY WERE DIVORCED
AND THEY COULD FLIP.
WHY NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEMS?
>> Jesse: WHOSE SIDE ARE YOU
ONE?
>> Jessica: RICH, PRETTY
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: I'M ON PLAIN, POORLY
MEN.
THE ONE DANA?
>> Dana: I'M ON HIS SIDE.
>> Jessica: THAT WAS A GOOD
ANSWER, GISELE.
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE IS THE
ONE WHO HAS SUFFERED THROUGH ALL
OF THIS AND SUPPORTED HER.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO TA